Finally, let us discuss in arrow B based out of order execution processor,
what really is out of order here? So this is our processor pipeline, let's say,
this is the fetch stage, there is a decode stage, we issue, then we dispatch and
then we have execution, and then the right of the result which is
the broadcast we have and then finally the commit. So in this pipeline,
if this was an out of order processor, keep in mind that not all of these stages
are processing instructions out of order. In fact, from fetch up to issue,
we are processing instructions in order. We have to fetch them in the order that
they should appear in the program. We then decode them in the correct order, and
we fetch them if you remember in order. This ensures that any dependencies we
figure out here are the dependencies that are compatible with the original
program order. Now that, we have issued instructions to reservation stations and
they're waiting for execution, they're going to execute in,
the order of data dependencies, not necessarily in program order. So
the execution and writing of results, are happening out of order. And then,
again, commit needs to do instructions in the proper program order because if
you remember the order of committing is really the order in
which we tell the outside world that we are finishing instructions. So,
this has to happen in order to give the appearance that we're executing
instructions in program order. So, when we have an out of order processor,
it really is going many stages in order and only the execution and broadcast and
things in between are happening out of order. So the dispatching, the execution,
the, the writing of results, everything else is still in order. In contrast,
what we would call an in-order processor, just as these in order too.
But even an out of order proser does a lot of things in order.